[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing why on
earth the majority of witches and
wizards in attendance the quidditch
world cup ran away from the invading
death eaters rather than stay and fight
why weren't the death eaters stopped
yes some did stay in fight but of the
vast numbers that attended only an
infinitesimal number stayed what i
wonder is why
the international quidditch world cup
was the premier quidditch contest hosted
every four years since its very first
contest in the year 1473. the quidditch
world cup allowed quidditch players from
all over the globe to find glory for
their respective countries as it
represented the pinnacle of quidditch
competition
for this reason it was exceedingly
popular with witches and wizards
traveling from all over the globe
to support their nation's quidditch team
the result more than a few boatloads of
witches and wizards were first
introduced to this spectacular event in
the goblet of fire
clutching their purchases mr weasley in
the lead they all hurried into the wood
following the lantern-lit trail
they could hear the sounds of thousands
of people moving around them shouts and
laughter snatches of singing
the atmosphere feverish excitement was
highly infectious
harry couldn't stop grinning they walked
through the wood for 20 minutes talking
and joking loudly until at last they
emerged on the other side and found
themselves in the shadow of a gigantic
stadium
though harry could only see a fraction
of the immense gold walls surrounding
the field
he could tell that ten cathedrals would
fit comfortably inside it
seats a hundred thousand said mr weasley
spotting the awestruck look on harry's
face
ministry task force of 500 have been
working on it all year in arthur
weasley's own words the quidditch world
cup stadium seated 100 000
that's a lot of magical folk but did
that many actually attend well a later
passage suggests that this is very much
the case
a hundred thousand witches and wizards
were taking their places in the seats
which rose in levels around the long
oval field
everything was suffused with a
mysterious golden light which seemed to
come from the stadium itself
okay so now that we've established that
over 100 000 magical folk were in
attendance at the quidditch world cup i
want to ask my question again
why on earth didn't they fight back
against the invading death eaters
to add to this not only were there just
100 000 people there was also the entire
ministry of magic including the
department of magical law enforcement a
department responsible for fighting back
against these types of dark wizards what
gives couldn't they have prevented the
riot and stopped the blatant torture of
muggles to refresh your memory after the
match between the irish and bulgarians
had finished the areas surrounding the
stadium were popping off with excitement
the irish fans were partying loudly and
all of those camping out outside of the
stadium were having a nice time harry
and his friends stay up late but
eventually fall asleep that is until
their rude awakening in the middle of
the night
quite suddenly mr weasley was shouting
get up run harry come on now get up this
is urgent harry sat up quickly and the
top of his head hit canvas
zamata he said
dimly he could tell that something was
wrong the noises in the campsite had
changed the singing had stopped he could
hear screams and the sound of people
running by the light of the few fires
that were still burning he could see
people running away into the woods
fleeing something that was moving across
the field toward them
something that was emitting odd flashes
of light and noises like gunfire
loud jeering roars of laughter and
drunken yells were drifting toward them
then came a burst of strong green light
which illuminated the scene
a crowd of wizards tightly packed and
moving together with ones pointing
straight upward was marching slowly
across the field
perry squinted at them they didn't seem
to have faces
then he realized that their heads were
hooded and their faces masked more
wizards were joining the marching group
laughing and pointing up the floating
bodies
tents crumpled and fell as the marching
crowd swelled
once or twice harry saw one of the
marchers blast a tent out of his way
with his wand several caught fire the
screaming grew louder
now we eventually find out that these
masked hooded wizards were death eaters
launching a haphazard potentially
drunken attack on the quidditch world
cup in order to cause mayhem and
somewhat portray loyalty to the dark
lord
the attack itself wasn't coordinated and
was more or less the dark wizard
equivalent of blowing off steam kind of
like when football hooligans take things
too far
still burning tents and torturing
muggles is alarming to say the least
which is what prompted some sort of
defense we're going to help the ministry
mr weasley shouted over all the noise
rolling up his own sleeves you lot get
into the woods and stick together i'll
come and fetch you when we've sorted
this out ministry wizards were dashing
from every direction toward the source
of the trouble
okay so ministry wizards and the
weasleys were making every effort to
confront these death eaters but what i
want to know is why they weren't stopped
based on what i can see from the chapter
the death eaters in the gob to fire it's
reasonable to deduce that there were
only 17 or so death eaters at the scene
of the crime
barty crouch jr avery wormtail lucius
malfoy walden mcnair crab goyle knot and
an unknown number of random death eaters
potentially alecto amicus carro raoul
yaxley selwyn wilkies gibbons jugson
karkarov wasn't there snape wasn't there
and the rest of the known death eaters
bellatrix rodolfos rabistan dolorhov
rookwood malzaber and travers were all
in azkaban at the time of the quidditch
world cup so again what was the big deal
about 17 primarily low to mid-level
death eaters causing a ruckus why
couldn't they be promptly stopped
couldn't they have been immediately
overpowered
okay with some analysis it looks like
there are a few things at play here i'm
going to start with one passage in
particular because i feel that it is of
particular importance
the crowd beneath the roberts family was
larger than ever they could see the
ministry wizards trying to get through
it to the hooded wizards in the center
but they were having great difficulty it
looked as though they were scared to
perform any spell that might make the
robert's family fool
what this passage suggests is that there
was a considerable effort from the
ministry wizards to reach the death
eaters but that there were so many
people in the way that they simply
couldn't do anything furthermore the
robert's family were being actively
tortured which meant that ministry
wizards were hesitant to pull the
trigger for fear that the roberts family
would be dropped from the air
okay so that's one reason that the death
eaters weren't stopped in their tracks
here are some of the others another
reason is that no one really knew quite
how many death eaters there actually
were the scene was pure chaos and what
started off with fireworks and screams
of joy quickly devolved into fearful
screams and tents being set ablaze
amidst the darkness of the campground
how could anyone have possibly known how
many there were all people were focused
on were the pointy hats the screaming
and the fire the attack came out of
nowhere i expect that this lack of
information certainly would have caused
the lay witch or wizard to lean towards
flight rather than fight
hence crowds of disorganized chaos
effectively preventing the real
defenders from reaching the death eaters
another factor to consider is of course
the psychological factor
despite voldemort's downfall the death
eaters still inspired a considerable
amount of fear into the hearts of
witches and wizards alike
if you suddenly saw death eaters and you
were drunk and unprepared you'd probably
freeze and just end up running away
which is what happened on mass
lastly there may have been 100 000
wizards in the entire ministry of magic
there but what we have to remember is
that many of these witches and wizards
were entirely unfit to fight
a lot of these fans were drunk scared
and completely caught off guard as for
the ministry a lot of ministry workers
are simply pencil pushers how are they
supposed to be expected to navigate a
random dark wizard attack that's what
the department of magical law
enforcement is for we know that
eventually the chaos ends with barty
crouch jr casting the dark mark into the
sky
prompting the death eaters to
disappearate and flee and fear
this is because these disloyal death
eaters were more than willing to engage
in muggle torture but not even remotely
willing to search for their former
master
and that's it for this video did you
guys ever wonder how the small number of
death eaters at the quidditch world cup
were able to get away unscathed if you
have any harry potter questions or video
requests please leave a comment down
below
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live